raven-symoné announces it she's a  leaving the view for a big reason I'm  excited the 30 year old actress who has  been a co-host since 2015 will make her  last appearance on the talk show later  this year I used to do the show called  That's So Raven and we're doing it  That's So Raven - I'm executive producer  so I've been super busy that's why I  haven't been here and I also yeah I'm  just the other side of it is is that I'm  gonna be leaving here this will be I'm  gonna be leaving at the end of the year  and before the I'm sorry before the  years of the years and I've had such a  great time Raven will be moving back to  Los Angeles from New York reprise her  role of a Raven Baxter in the new comedy  but this time it shall be a mom casting  for Ravens kids will be Gannett soon  some people have that x-factor the  original That's So Raven ran from 2003  until 2007 and was one of the Disney  Channel's of biggest successes ever  you